in 2005 investors were euphoric about
the booming housing market financial
institutions raked in billions of
dollars financing real estate Ventures
riding the wave of financial success but
then the wave broke and it all came
crashing down one in 10 Americans
couldn't afford their mortgage nearly 10
million Americans lost their homes to
foreclosure housing prices fell 30% from
their highs and in big cities like Miami
they dropped around 40% the result was
the worst global economic crisis since
the Great Depression despite the
disaster one trader triumphed John
pulson predicted the housing market
would collapse he bet against it even
when other investors laughed him off and
here's the thing Paulson didn't know a
thing about real estate investing he was
an expert in mergers and Acquisitions
yet during the market meltdown when
other firms lost billions of dollars he
made 20 billion for his firm and his
clients that's why it's called the Great
greatest trade ever this is the story of
how an outsider pulled off the greatest
trade of all time before the crisis
unfolded John Paulson was a small fish
in a big pond in 2005 his funds only
gained 5% below the average of 9% at
other hedge funds at age 49 he was also
older than many of his peers who were in
their 20s and 30s he had catching up to
do because after attending NYU and
Harvard Business School he went into
Consulting first but he realized he'd
rather make money for himself than
advise others on how to do it so he got
a job at Investment Bank be Sterns and
then Gru where he gained valuable
experience and also partied hard after
hours despite Rising through the ranks
he sensed that greater opportunities lay
ahead in 1994 he started his own hedge
fund pulson and Co trouble is the phone
didn't ring no one wanted to invest with
it as pson recounted to Gregory
Zuckerman in his book The Greatest trade
ever it was hard to be rejected it was
was a lonely period after a while I said
this is too much he lifted my spirits
referring to his dad hson also clung to
Winston Churchill's famous never give up
commencement speech since no one would
take a chance on him he decided to take
a chance on himself he started his firm
with $2 million of his own money it took
him a full year to find his first client
he barely had enough resources to hire
employees though he did hire an
assistant Jenny zaharia who had later
become his wife in the 90s his fur
managed tens of millions of dollars
whereas the big hedge funds managed
hundreds of millions but the events of
911 would changed the trajectory of his
firm in response to the shock and
uncertainty the Federal Reserve cut
interest rates to try to stimulate the
economy this made borrowing cheaper
including for mortgages allowing more
people to afford homes yet this
inadvertently laid the groundwork for
the housing crisis Banks and other
mortgage lenders started loosening their
standards offering mortgages even to
those with poor credit if you were a
borrower you had no credit you had a
horrible credit rate um you had a
history of never paying your money back
and you had no cash to put down to buy
the house they would still lend you a
100 this case
110% of the purchase price of the house
so you can actually buy the house with
no money down and get 10% of the
purchase price in your pocket as crazy
as that may Sound by 2005 24% of all
mortgages required no down payment up
from 3% in 2001 these risky loans known
as subprime mortgages were appealing to
lenders due to their higher interest
rates Banks packaged these subprime
mortgages into bundles and sold them to
investment Banks like Leman brothers and
Marl Lynch which converted these bundles
into mortgage backed Securities selling
them to a range of investors worldwide
from Japanese Pension funds to Swiss
banks when an increasing number of
homeowners couldn't afford their
mortgage payments leading to widespread
defaults it triggered a domino effect
through the financial system which
experts failed to foresee according to
Moody's and
SNP U there had never been a default of
an investment grade mortgage back
security never being I guess post World
War II or post
1950 and we said oh well they did
default in the Great Depression they
said well unless you think we're going
going to have a Great Depression you
know we don't think mortgage Securities
are going to default and they'd laugh
but pulson didn't think the past would
predict the future given the risky
mortgages being issued the only thing
that kept these mortgages afloat was
that housing prices were Rising rapidly
if you couldn't pay your mortgage and
defaulted the lender would take back the
house but would still profit as the
property value went up but what would
happen if housing prices started to fall
Pao Pelini wondered the same he had
asked pulson for a job after his career
had derailed convinced that his Italian
accent had hurt him Pelini poured over
mountains of housing data and noticed a
troubling Trend home prices had
increased an average of 1.4% between
1975 to 2000 factoring in inflation but
afterward soared 7% a year on average
from 2000 to 2005 hinting at a bubble
his analysis also showed that when
housing prices fell in the past they
dropped below the trend line suggesting
when the housing market corrected it
would be brutal Gan pson viewed the
housing market as a house of cards bound
to collapse when housing prices fell it
was kind of a you know a very simple
physics problem if home prices kept
falling and went negative and
delinquencies kept rising at some point
the mortgage Market would cor collapse
and then these mortgages would sustain
losses it became very obvious to us but
the the problem is the Machinery the
factories that were just geared up to
buying mortgages securitizing and
selling them they just were oblivious to
the what was going on and they couldn't
stop the machine Pelini proposed that
they bet against risky mortgages by
purchasing credit default swaps credit
default swaps or CDs acted like
Insurance on mortgage-backed Securities
it's like buying insurance for a house
if the house catches on fire which can
be compared to a default on the mortgage
backed security the insurance company or
the seller of the credit default swap
compensates the buyer the cost of
insurance was only around 1% of the
amount being protected for example it
costs 10 million annually to ensure $1
billion of mortgage backed Securities if
their bet didn't go well they'd lose 10
million but if the Securities defaulted
they'd get 1 billion in essence we risk
1% in order to make 100% if they
defaulted within the average timeline of
these uh CDs which were about two years
so it was a very screed trade where you
lost little if the trade didn't work but
you made a lot if if it did work
understanding credit default swaps
required specialized knowledge Pelini
educated himself through tutorials
provided by Bar's Brokers and also at
industry conferences their strategy
involved targeting the riskier mortgage
back Securities mortgage backed
Securities are divided into different
layers or slices known as tranches each
tranch has a different level of risk the
top trenches like AAA are considered the
safest the bottom ones the riskiest hson
strategically targeted Triple B slices
believing that a housing collapse would
impact Triple B rated tranches more than
the safe for a1s his firm bought $25
billion worth of credit default swaps
with all the major Banks the total value
insured was substantial even with only a
1% annual premium hson established a new
fund dedicated to setting against
subprime mortgages on a large scale
however finding investors was difficult
because few believed in his strategy as
described in zuckerman's book Jeffrey
tant of the hedge fund prote Partners
said people on trading desks warned pson
doesn't have expertise in the area or he
doesn't know what he's doing a Bear
Sterns expert said you guys need to do
more research on historical price
appreciation when Paulson asked what are
your models based on the expert replied
our models are fine we' been doing this
for 20 years pson found himself
bewildered by the lack of interest in
his fund he lamented I don't know why
they don't get it this is the trade of a
lifetime he ended up scrounging together
147 million for his new fund mostly from
friends there were a few others who
foresaw collapse but they weren't as
determined as pulson and they didn't
invest nearly as much unlike pulson
Michael bu failed to convince investors
to support a dedicated fund for betting
against subprime mortgages when
investors started withdrawing money from
his firm he reluctantly began to sell
his credit default swaps despite scoring
half a billion in gains for his firm he
wondered what might have been if he
hadn't been forced to sell some of his
positions early Andrew L's boss was
furious at his bearish housing bets and
fired him so he set up his own hedge
fund and earned 100 million for his
clients and 10 million for himself when
he retired he wrote a letter sticking it
to those who failed to see the warning
sign of a crash I was in this for the
money the loow hanging fruit I.E idiots
whose parents paid for Prep School Yale
and then the Harvard MBA was there for
the taking Greg Litman at Deutsche Bank
played a crucial role in facilitating
credit default swap contracts for py
litman's own bets against housing were
successful but the troubles at his bank
meant he was only given a few million as
a bonus Paulson had encouraged his
friend real estate millionaire Jeffrey
green to invest in his fund but green
decided to secure credit default swap
contracts on his own which pson viewed
as a stab in the back green pocketed 500
million on his bets although all of
these investors walked away very wealthy
none matched the scale of Paulson's
earnings pulson went all in certain
everything would collapse in addition to
shorting mortgage-backed Securities his
team also shorted banks that had large
quantities of subprime mortgages New
Century Fanny May Freddy Mack City Bank
Washington Mutual Indie MAAC bear Stern
Leman Brothers Paulson's top Trader Brad
Rosenberg summed it up this way we had
to get on as many trades as possible
before it was too late the weight
however seemed endless by late 2006 the
housing market was slowing down yet the
widespread mortgage defaults they
anticipated hadn't yet occurred the main
obstacle was the role of collateralized
debt obligations these complex Financial
products which bundled various types of
debt including mortgage back Securities
masked the true risks in the market they
were like the sturdier lower blocks of a
tower about to fall over delaying the
inevitable collapse Paulson reassured
his concerned wife Jenny saying it's
just a matter of
waiting the collapse began in late 2006
when New Century one of the largest
subprime mortgage lenders reported an
unexpected loss as its borrowers
struggled to pay their loans in 2007 two
big hedge funds run by be Conns that
were heavily invested in subprime
mortgage back Securities imploded
triggering Market chaos the heads of
City group and meil Lynch were ousted
and then in September 2008 Leeman
Brothers went under the largest
bankruptcy in US history that sent shock
waves through the financial system the
US government stepped in to rescue the
government sponsored Enterprises Fanny
May and Freddy Mack guaranteeing over
$300 billion of debt motivated by desire
to stabilize the housing market The
Fallout from the financial crisis was
devastating 10 million American
homeowners faced foreclosure
unemployment soared and retirement
savings and Investments plummeted as the
stock market fell
60% and yet in the turmoil pson saw an
unprecedented opportunity and it changed
his life pson and Co earned 15 billion
in 2007 with pson himself making 4
billion over the next 2 years his firm
added another 5 billion with pulson
taking home 2 billion he was no longer a
mediocre player but a Wall Street Legend
poo Pelini who is often overshadowed by
pulson was rewarded with 175 million in
2007 the possibility that we're in
another housing bubble is Up For Debate
the 2008 crisis led to significant
regulatory changes like stricter lending
standards to try to avert another dis
disaster yet despite these measures
future bubbles can't be ruled out
financial markets are complex and
influenced by a wide range of factors
including economic policies market
conditions and investor Behavior John
Paulson's story is a powerful reminder
of the value of in-depth analysis and
independent thinking even when few
believed him sometimes the most
insightful decisions are those that go
against the grain Smart Financial
choices start with the right trading
platform and Mumu stands out Mumu is a
trading app with zero commissions on
trading stocks ETFs and options what I
really like about Mumu is that it is
very user friendly with everything that
you need it can visually present to you
everything from Individual stock chart
Trends to company financial data for
example I wanted to learn about John
polson's latest moves so I located his
firm pson and Co and discovered that he
added 2.8 million shares of gold stocks
it's not a bad way to copy homework from
professional investors
in certain markets mumi offers a cash
Suite program where the money you
haven't invested can earn interest in
the US new users have a limited time
opportunity to earn 5.1% apy plus an
extra 3% apy along with up to 15 free
stocks don't miss out on this exciting
offer available until February 29th and
good news for Canadians Mumu has
launched its RSP tfsa accounts just in
time for the RSP contribution deadline
on February 29th you can start by
contributing as little as $100 to your
RSP or tfsc account and receive $50 in
cash rewards with the potential to
accumulate up to
$1,550 in cash rewards in Australia just
by signing up you can earn a fantastic
6.8% per anim interest for the first 180
days plus score up to 10 free stocks
with eligible deposits and if you're
worried about fund safety Dopey your
funds are backed by $1 million of FDIC
insurance offering the same security as
traditional Banks start making smarter
Financial choices today by signing up
with my custom link in the description
thanks for watching for news think I'm
Cindy pal